take a good look at this a pretty cool
story coming out of san francisco
edge innovations an engineering company
there is working on creating a robot
dolphin this would be a cruelty free
game changer for marine parks
looks almost identical to the real thing
doesn't it 550 pounds with
silicone-grade
skin it nod swims and can withstand
close contact with humans
providing an alternative to capturing
breeding and training live animals
it's kind of surprising they're like 3
000 dolphins and currently in captivity
being used
to generate several billions of dollars
just for dolphin
experiences and so there's obviously an
appetite
to to love and learn about dolphins and
so
we want to use that appetite and and
offered kind of different ways to to
fall in love with a dolphin
edge by the way has developed
animatronics used for hollywood
blockbusters like free willy
but their dolphins certainly do not come
cheap with a price tag of about 26
million dollars
that's a huge obstacle for the creators
you know proving that the robotic sea
creatures will work out to be cheaper in
the long run than the real thing
and i know we're all about whatever you
can do to help our
our creatures in the wild stay in the
wild right denise
of course yeah and of course you know in
the long run there's also a price you
got to pay on the humanity of
keeping an animal captive like that so
they have to measure but 26 million
dollars is a pretty steep
price tag for a lot of people goodness
but it's good they're efforting all of
this
yeah and they look so real it's amazing
it's almost a little creepy when it
comes up next to you they're doing a
great